let's bring in dave ribbon the host of
the ribbon report on youtube uh davis to
this idea that the migrants were being
misled about where they were going the
only thing i saw was that the migrants
who were dropped off at the naval
observatory today thought that they were
going to union station
it might have been turned uh you know uh
this idea that this is becoming
increasingly political that greg
abbott's bussing migrants to the gates
of the naval observatory desantis is
flying them to martha's vineyard lori
lightfoot the mayor of chicago was
bussing the ligaments from downtown
chicago to a republican suburb of burr
ridge the mayor of el paso was bussing
them to new york city but nobody's
complaining about that i mean it's
getting beyond political but you can't
get away from the fact that more than
two million people have crossed the
border
and that something's got to give here
right so let's deal with that part first
um
two million people crossing the border
that is the job of the federal
government so if we're just looking
where do you lay blame first forgetting
whether you think people should go to
sanctuary cities or not or whether it's
okay to bust people or put them on
planes number one everyone has to
understand if we're looking for who
started this problem it is 100 percent
the biden administration no matter what
john corinne pierre says
it is their job as the federal
government to protect our borders that's
number one number two as for what's now
happening where they're bouncing across
you know state lines and into different
cities and all that i actually think
this is quite good because it is
bursting forth the fundamental
difference between democrat policies and
republican policies i am a very proud
new floridian and i love the fact that
ron desantis warned the federal
government he warned the biden
administration what he was going to do
he said if they come here or say he said
we're sending them to dc or martha's
vineyards well he did martha's vineyard
and i suspect he'll send him to dc too
texas is doing the exact same thing
you're seeing states say okay if the
federal government will not do their job
one of the few things the federal
government is supposed to do which is
protect our borders then hey go ahead
and go to these sanctuary cities and
it's really funny too because the
democrats are freaking out now that and
the media is freaking out that they're
showing up in martha's vineyard and
these and chicago and other democrat-run
cities but it's like don't you guys care
about immigrants i thought everybody's
welcome nobody's illegal etc etc
although now dc's uh their homeless
shelters are being overrun by illegals
so they're struggling too but the point
is that it's it's exposing the nonsense
of the policies and i think that's good
yeah these cities call themselves
sanctuary cities and yet when the people
seeking sanctuary come there they're not
particularly happy about it abbott sent
the bus right to the naval observatory
after kamala harris said this over the
weekend and meet the press listen to
this
border is secure but we also have a
broken immigration system in particular
over the last four years before we came
in and it needs to be fixed we're gonna
have two million people cross this
border for the first time ever you're
confident this border's secure
we have
a secure border
in that that is a priority for any
nation
so she insists on multiple occasions
there that the border is secure but
listen to what a migrant from venezuela
who came on one of those buses to the
naval observatory told our griff jenkins
just this morning
vice president harris
said that the border is closed
is the border closed do you believe that
the border is closed or is it open it's
open not close the water is open
the border is open do you believe that
all the migrants believe that the border
is open yeah everybody believe that
their body is open it's open because we
enter we come in
free
no problem how did you learn
that the border
was open to come illegally how did you
learn to come
because we sit on the news
that everybody coming illegally so we
actually do the same you know
so what that migrant said to griff
jenkins would seem to stand in sharp
contradiction to what the vice president
claimed dave
yeah look i'm sympathetic to that guy's
plight and if the news in where he's
coming from wherever whatever country
he's coming from is telling him hey the
border's open and then everyone's going
the borders open and then he gets here
and the borders open thus he is in
american territory well then who's
telling the truth is it him who's here
now illegally or is it kamala harris she
has one job she seems incapable of doing
it she refuses to visit the border and
you know look a nation is only a nation
she she blamed trump in essence she said
the previous four years uh donald trump
wanted to build a wall and remember what
everybody said when he wanted to build a
wall and and you know put up electric
fences and monitoring all that everyone
said he was racist so is it now the
policies of the democrats who apparently
are very pro-border
are they racist now of course not so
again we're exposing a lot of the
hypocrisy in the policies and i think
this should just continue let's you know
i think this uh martha's vineyard the
the area there they just put out a
warning about the uh the influx of
people and it's like that's 50 people
who just showed up on those planes what
do you think has been going down at the
texas border towns for years and years
they didn't have a lot of sympathy then
no clearly they didn't dave great to get
your thoughts on this appreciate it if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell